Hello, we already delayed it enough.
Hello, everyone.
Yo!
I can't believe you said I was pooping.
Well, I'm like...
Oh, you were?
I was!
Yes, I was!
Because I was like, what did she say?
What did she say?
So...
Do you speak Spanish?
No, I don't speak Spanish.
But you heard that.
So, okay, you can't say that.
We're sponsored now.
Bonita.
We're sponsored right now.
You can't say that even if it's another language.
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry.
but hello everyone hey guys at chibi's chat because i know
you've been streaming for a while already um but today it's
a special day i'm taking my child to work day i came back
with milk again um i'm so happy yeah it's her designated
weekend to spend time with me i know yeah yeah it's you know
her mom you know was like this is your day today to look
after chibi um and then uh so now Chibi to my job and today
what are we going to be doing today Chibi we are going to be
playing infinity Nikki let's go we're going to be reacting
to a video about I was like well much plan changed plans
plan changed you're like you know 50% right it's okay she's
my kid she's she's allowed to make mistakes she's a child
yeah I'm sorry you they grow up to be Chibi Doki it's crazy
so we are going to be checking out infinity Nikki today you
so much for sponsoring the both of us to do a little uh
reaction time to the newest update for their anniversary um
and i think like the last 10 minutes we're going to be
looking through some outfits that are going to be launched
with the anniversary as well and apparently it's a very very
big change have you played infinity nikki yet i played what
one of the nikki games on mobile a long time ago because i
was really into like fashion games as a kid yeah yeah and
When this game came out, I was actually really excited.
I played it for a couple hours when it first came out.
Yeah, this is actually my first time playing Niki.
So, which is, I guess, good because they're changing a lot
for the newest update.
So they're making it open world now.
So I assume it's a lot different from when you played it,
right?
Because it was more about like fashion and configuring
outfits and stuff.
More linear, yeah.
And like, this is going to be more like explorative and
it'll be really fun, I think.
yeah yeah so yeah they apparently it's like a whole they
were saying that it's a whole new thing um like what you
played before is going to be very different from what it is
now or like the newest update and it doesn't feel like it's
a new patch basically it's like entirely new game because
they added the whole open world concept to it yeah so that's
so cool chibi and i we were trying to do the tutorial for
for the game and then um there was a lot of lore because
like the lore was how there's a whale yeah there's a whale
in space and you're like reborn into something also we
danced with a beautiful girl that was my favorite part yeah
she was that's what she was doing that's what she was doing
while like she was in the chat just going through the
tutorial and stuff um and uh so yeah there's gonna be a lot
of new things to it uh and they gave us this live stream
that is gonna showcase all the new updates and i'm looking
forward to it uh let's see let me all right so there's
apparently there's a very long intro to the video because
there's like a 10 minute intro should we skip ahead yeah we
got i'm not gonna like watch a 10 minute time with tv i know
the clock's not frozen guys we just tried to uh we just
tried and skip it's a pre-recorded video um also i need to
remember i need to pin my me a pin the oh yes yes the yeah
click the link on our panel since we're watching it
separately should we do like a countdown at a certain time
okay okay yeah no I'm just gonna like be like 20 minutes
ahead of you you're gonna spoil it yeah I'll be like oh yeah
here's a spoiler alert for you it's like ooh alright let me
pin I'm gonna get the countdown to zero one zero right like
so I can be started yeah yeah yeah give me a sec let me I
need to grab the, I need to pin the link in my chat.
No, take your time.
I need to, like, get the video set up.
Check out the game here to support the stream.
Infinity.
Niki.
But yes, thank you again for sponsoring us.
We're the Doki Squares.
Actually a very good game.
The tutorial was, like, the most artistic tutorial I've ever
played in the game.
Yeah, thank you for providing the child support for me, for
my child.
Thank you.
Thank you for showing up.
She's a very expensive kid.
really what's explicit about me is it the fortnight like is
it like all the fortnight and roblox wait what do you mean
wait whose credit card your moms are mine you don't want to
know let's not ask questions wait a minute i've actually
like one of my mom's friends um son stole her credit card
and maxed it out for
for cosmetics that's insane I look like I stole a penny from
my mom and I got caught and I cried like I I can't do it
yeah stealing the credit card that's crazy alright let me
check my time I'm at oh wait okay oh I'm at 959 that's 0.0
at the start I don't know I'm at 9 oh I'm at 959 as well
whoa whoa twins oh wait no you're my daughter I don't know.
The timeline's confusing.
I don't know.
The timeline's a little confusing there.
Alright, let me adjust your volume real quick before...
Okay.
Yeah, let's get closer to Mike if you want to.
Alright, ready?
Okay, we'll do a countdown.
Okay, I'm going.
Three, two, one.
Start.
Go!
Whoa.
Straight in it.
Oh.
In the darkness.
There's the light.
I'm watching it through my through my OBS.
Oh, yeah.
Me too, yeah.
Pretty.
I'd love to see the art book for this game.
I know.
Like the fashion, all the fashion outfits that you can do.
It's the last 10 minutes of the of the stream.
We're going to be looking through the new outfits that
they're going to be showcasing for the new anniversary.
I love cute clothes.
Me too.
Like, I like seeing fashion.
I just don't like wearing it because, like, it takes no fair
enough.
Yeah.
It takes so much time to, like, you know, get prepared to go
out.
And then, like, if you wear a cute outfit, that means you
have to make your hair cute and then your face cute.
And it's like, I'm not.
That's why we're V-Tubers.
Yeah, exactly.
We don't have to do any of that.
You might do that every street.
That's a bit too much.
Yeah, you gotta touch grass and we have to dress up as well.
Like pick one.
I know.
I like, I am showering three days.
Yeah, okay.
Not like her though.
That's- Oh, what?
Oh, me neither.
I was just kidding.
Like, that's from her mom's side, not from me.
Oh, she's emoting.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, I think my dog just started whining.
No, I think that's just from... That's just you.
Are you sure?
I don't know.
Wait, she swapped outfits.
Slay.
Wait, where did the dragon come from?
Wait, are we going to...
Are we going to dress up the dragon?
Are we going to get the dragon a cute outfit too?
We're trying to save the dragon.
Save the dragon from his horrible fashion sense.
Oh, no!
Or maybe we're harvesting him for material to make pieces.
Oh, you're right.
It's like 101 donations.
Yeah, we're going to wear scales.
We're gonna use Take his eyelashes Yeah Her eyelashes will
go so well On my jacket Oh I got it Not the shoes
We gotta We gotta harvest that dragon For fashion Oh my god
Those feathers will go so well She's about to alt She's
pressing Q Oh my gosh When she alts She changes fashion
That's the alt Oh When she's taking the dragon for our oh my
god sweet oh
it's a painting oh i guess it's like oh he's a fun guy he
didn't wear papers he's really gonna poop my pants don't you
wear adult underwear wait what what the spread rumors about
wow this game looks so realistic Oh my god, the graphics are
insane.
I'm Alina and it's so great to see you again.
And even though you probably right now him, let me give a
proper introduction to my co-host.
From Infinity Nikki team, please welcome Johnny.
Hey stylist, it's me again.
Hello, that's right.
Here's Johnny.
Oh, here's Johnny.
To represent the team at Infinity Nikki and talk to you
about all the new content coming your way in version 2.0.
Welcome.
Now, as I'm sure all of you noticed, the two of us made the
effort to dress up for today's live stream.
Styling ourselves in a look inspired by Itzalan, a brand new
region that stylists can explore.
We also styled ourselves.
Yeah.
I put cheese on my head.
Hey, Johnny.
What do you think of the outfit I put together for today's
live stream?
I tried to give it a little bit of Itzalan vibe.
You know, I think you look amazing.
This look really fits you and it perfectly matches the vibe
of version 2.0.
I did try my best.
It's hard to believe, but it's almost been a full universe
of Infinity Niki launched.
Over the past year, Niki and Momo have traveled through
Flora Wish, Rizzie Meadow, Stoneville, and Wishing Woods,
making new friends and creating so many wonderful memories
along the way.
In version 2.0, Niki and Momo will be leaving the familiar
lands of Wishfield and beginning a brand new journey from
this time to the destination is its land.
I like Momo.
Oh, so they added like a whole new area.
earlier.
It actually contained a lot of top secret information.
For example, those ancient murals, the mysterious ritual,
that massive shadowy figure, and that curious mark appearing
on the back of Nikki's neck.
They all feel like they're hinting at a hidden truth of
sorts.
I can't take it anymore.
Let's stop teasing and jump right in.
We can't wait to show you everything, stylists.
You know, I agree, but before we get into the specifics, how
about we start things off with a round of giveaways for our
stylists really is it us is this real for real that's right
are we involved do i get a dragon yeah yeah can we each get
our own dragon to put make it to our code every one of our
stylists oh type guys type eats the land on our street guys
type to feel it yeah guys if you type it out you're entered
into the 50 giveaway don't be giving away 50 yeah yeah real
A list of winners will be pinned in the comments and shared
on our official social media.
If you're one of the lucky winners, take a screenshot of
your YouTube ID.
Oh, take a screenshot.
Yeah.
Your YouTube ID though.
Are you guys ready?
Are you sure?
Then let's go.
Wow, version 2.0 is so different.
It really, really is.
Let me ask you what really stuck out to you that was
different from version 1.0.
Yeah, GBU.
What is different?
I barely played it.
I know it's more open world and more focused on adventuring
and- Oh, I heard it's combat now too.
Yes, I- Dude, there's like classes and weapon- It's so cool.
Yeah, I saw there's like archery, which is like shooting a
gun.
But medieval- You're good at that.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll pin the winner list in the comments and share it on
our official social media later.
So you can stop submitting entries.
Also, don't forget to check after the stream to see if
you're one of our lucky winners.
I bet our stylist just can't wait to find out more about it.
Might win $50.
That's awesome.
Because right now, we're going to find out exactly what kind
of brand new adventure Nikki and Momo are about to embark
on.
That's right, stylist, it's time to reveal the PV for
version 2.0.
Yay!
That's where I have psoriasis.
You're, what?
Sorry.
She got her glowing mark.
That's where I have psoriasis.
I feel like her right now.
That's how I got it, actually.
It just started glowing.
Oh, there's the archer.
There's the archery.
That is so...
In video games, I always like to go for archer.
That is so cool.
Oh, yeah, because it's like long range, too.
Oh, wait.
It's so pretty.
Oh my god, there's...
See, I knew he was wearing a diaper.
Yeah, see, I told you.
Does he have a problem?
Like, IBS?
I don't know.
You seem to know a lot about these problems.
Are you talking from experience?
Listen, man.
We don't need to talk about the diaper.
I'm wearing it, man.
I understand.
It was awesome.
Look, there he is.
I knew he was a baby or an adult.
We don't know.
Oh, that's a cute outfit, though.
Oh, my God.
That's a John-ass...
How is he able to lift himself?
Oh, my gosh.
Tokyo Drifting.
Play the Eurobeat.
Gosh, these snails...
Oh, my God.
These snails are so fast.
Did you ever play snail mail on the phone?
Snail mail?
Yeah, it was a mobile game.
Where your snail delivered mail to other planet.
When did that came out?
I was, like, 10 years old.
Oh, yeah, okay, but, like, what year?
So, like, I don't know, like, 2008?
Oh, I like that guy's mourns.
Okay, but who plays the guy in this game, though?
You gotta slay as a cute girl.
Yeah, always a cute girl.
I will not be able to come with the mushroom gun.
Yeah, like, who invented Who invited this guy?
He thinks he's part of the tea.
I know, I think Bro thinks he's part of the tea.
Yeah,
I'd rather be the muster.
You're right.
No, I won't be the muster.
I mean, he is slaying, though.
Yeah, I've been looking at him.
He's really good.
Oh, my God.
That's the combat.
We have to fight that guy.
My sick-ass outfit.
Weaponize these heels.
Oh, Oh!
That's cute.
To see the truth.
Even if it upends everything we once firmly believed.
2.0 is coming, guys!
Yay!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, cool!
Oh, that has to be the archery stuff.
I feel like every part of this game could be like a really
pretty background.
Yeah.
I mean, oh my gosh.
Oh, the lion.
The title.
Is that the dragon?
Yeah, I was gonna say the lion.
Well, he has lion down.
Bro, look at that giant-ass lion over there.
This is actually really beautiful.
I want to go there.
Like, apparently, the fact that they made, like, an entirely
new game out of the concept.
Yeah.
Because they were willing to, like, because they were, like,
trying to fix what a lot of users had issues with earlier.
Yeah.
And just giving a whole other new experience.
That's weird to, like, try and make things better like not
just like little changes but really big changes for the
enjoyment of the players that's like games rarely do that
nowadays oh also i just saw that you saw the outfits have
like abilities too because she like went raw and then the
flash like oopsie i remember when i played this game like
certain uh outfits had like there was like double jump and
like certain attacks yeah it was cool
oh let's see built all this i'm apparently covering the
little graphic on the far right oh wait are we are am I also
in the corner on the right side you're I you're social
distancing from me oh I'm social distancing on you yeah you
didn't want to sit next to me even though like I put the
chair there you got you moved it and you're like no I was
like even shower in three days and look I was just like look
um your mom just said I had to spend time with you not that
to be next to you your mom said I had to spend time with you
not that I like cute oh she's tidy oh oh there's puzzles too
oh we get dead oh gritty yes i remember seeing on twitter
one of the cut scenes it was like in the tutorial the girl
with the big wings it was like a dance yeah i remember like
some of the fights being dances oh my god i take pictures oh
cute oh like oh yeah because it's like you know you'll take
pictures of the like your cute outfit for the
oh it's like a like search you're digging through the sand i
love that outfit oh oh my god you get a sword that's my
favorite outfit so far i think my favorite one was the was
the one when she was in that bubble earlier that one was
cute oh wait that's just amalie oh oh the forest okay i
think worst book in the show oh no no no deepwood deepwood
deepwood deepwood yeah yeah that's yeah i would wear that i
would actually okay the lush one is cute too a burning heart
i would wear that that is so cute oh the mysterious
adventurer it's like western yeah deepwood deepwood's my
favorite so far that one is really good welcome back to our
preview live stream that was the pv version 2.0 on November
25th, UTC7.
Hey, Johnny, I'm sure everyone feels the same way I do.
After watching the PV, I've got so many questions.
The brand new five-star resonance outfits, Niki wielding a
bow, new abilities, trials, and challenges.
Is this still the Infinity Niki we know and love?
Not to worry, we'll be diving into all of that and more in
today's version 2.0 preview live stream.
On top of that, to mark the one-year anniversary Infinity
Nikki, we've prepared a ton of special in-game events,
real-world events, and special anniversary rewards just for
our family.
Oh, exciting.
Just for us, guys.
You're doing it for us.
We'll be launching a whole slew of birthday-themed events
and rewards as well.
We seriously have so much we want to share with you today,
we literally may not have enough time to get through it all.
Nevertheless, be sure to stay tuned for the entire Preview
Live stream.
Exactly.
I'm super excited.
Yeah.
So why don't we start by having Johnny walk us through the
setting of version 2.0 It's a land.
From what we saw in the PV, It's a land feels like a wild,
free and fantastical land.
And the ancient Titan civilization that once lived there
left behind some ruins, didn't they?
Wow, you're pretty observant.
Well, with that said, let me give everyone a simple yet
proper introduction to It's a land.
Starting in version 2.0, Nikki and Momo will be venturing
into Elderwood Forest Oh, oh my god, that's a giant ass
shell.
Imagine the echo in there.
Now, as the name suggests, Elderwood Forest is a vast,
endless woodland filled with all kinds of extraordinary
natural wonders.
From the ethereal and mysterious mother shroom woods.
And the mushroom people died?
No!
Was that the dragon from the start?
I don't know, though, that's way too big.
Because I'm like thinking, you know, anything for fashion,
you know?
And I think, like, that mushroom cat will make it look like
a good hat.
A good hat, yeah.
I know, right?
It'll be a good hat.
I like the way you think.
Exactly.
I feel like we should be able to harvest any individual in
this forest.
It'd be a very different game.
Anything for fashion.
Oh, by the way.
Oh.
So what's your step?
That's right.
And perched high on a cliff, that giant snail shell you see
is the life.
lively city of Spira.
Wait, that's a snail show?
Look!
Look at the cost.
I don't know.
That must have been a lot of salt.
One of the most fascinating aspects of Spira is its snail
culture.
Getting around and sporting goods, everything relies on
snails.
Wouldn't that be a really slow knock?
But what if like, what if someone actually, like, that's
like a terrible thing to rely on because you just pour salt
on them.
That goes super fast.
Yeah, and the sun like burns them.
snail at least once but maybe they're like better snails
like highly evolved snails where you can't even kill it with
salt maybe they're immortal i'm sure nikki's time with them
that sounds terrible and laughter so now nikki's loving it
oh i heard like snail glue is really good for your skin yeah
snail needs yeah i'm definitely coming back to get like free
skincare every corner of this yeah you're just like oh my oh
yeah so it's like drifting with snails
It's like turbo.
The Park Solians.
The Park Solians are similar in size to humans, but their
most striking features are the horns on their foreheads and
tails on their backs.
Banish him.
He's different.
Do they have some connection with dragons?
Well, long, long ago.
I mean, we could, like, harvest the horns for fashion, too.
Yeah, look like rhinos.
Yeah.
Rhinos don't deserve it.
it but like maybe these guys's horns grow back yeah they
grow back in the tail too yeah imagine you see oh it's like
a bella the fabric on the tail you know the fur yeah you use
the fur to make like so rich in this i know right journey as
long as i have no mores
i'm gonna i'm gonna take his tail and make it into a nice
scarf Nikki and places upon her a strange otherworldly mark
and just like that a new adventure begins while on this
journey Nikki and Momo will meet many new friends and
acquaintances including the shroomlings and the park solians
among them is a shroomling there's my favorite character
right there a courageous shroomling hero who will accompany
Nikki oh yeah he looks so brave I wonder we can like we can
like dress him up girl yeah i don't want to dress him up who
has come to it's a land at first glance she seems ordinary
but you soon get the feeling she knows something no one else
does and then like her makeup founder of it's a land's
docileism the high priestess medale she holds tremendous
influence in this place which means everyone will need to
tread very
or like yeah use the horns as like the for the ends of the
heel exactly or like just use it as like a like a like those
like headbatters like headgear or put them on a headband so
we can pretend to be like them unknown challenges ahead
nikki will certainly or use as like a show like put it on
the shoulders too like a shoulder pad thing yeah let me take
this part this is what i've been to share with you stylists.
In version 2.0, Niki will gain four brand new abilities.
They are archery, sticky claw, or grappling, gigantication,
and battle companion.
These abilities are not only connected to the map of
Itzaland, but they will also enrich Niki's adventure and
bring a whole new dimension to the Oh, I love this one.
That's my favorite.
That one's my favorite.
At the very beginning of version 2.0, when Niki first
arrives in Itzaland, she'll unlock the archery ability and
receive the four-star ability outfit, Purifying Wind.
For this outfit, Nikki takes inspiration.
I guess each outfit matches with the ability.
With her short hair and bow in hand, she looks sharp and
cool.
That's right.
Once Nikki unlocks the archery ability, she'll be able to
use her arrows to purify dark essence, handle dangerous
situations, take on bigger challenges, and reach places she
never could before.
That looks difficult.
We also want to show another side of Nikki in version 2.0, a
side that can be gentle and calm, yet sharp and decisive
when needed.
Just like the wind, she's free, untamed, and impossible to
hold back.
Oh, and there's a fun fact.
Nikki was born in December, so she's actually a Sagittarius.
What a coincidence.
Oh, no lie.
I'm a Cancer.
Anyway, in version 2.0, Nikki embraces her role as a true
sharpshooter.
Every arrow shift.
That's the crab.
No, I'm just thinking of you as a crab, you know?
That's what I'm thinking of, you know?
That's what it is.
What are you implying?
Crab's are okay.
What's wrong with crab?
Yeah, your mom had sponsors.
Sponsor, thank you so much.
Sponsor.
One thing stylists need to know is that my mom had pet
crabs.
How did you know that?
You can also greatly enhance Nikki's ability to explore an
area with it.
can aim at distant objects to activate mechanisms.
Oh, she's my grandma.
Let's items from afar and even shoot down a Wimstar.
Aside from archery, Nikki's other new abilities are just as
impressive.
Take this to you all, for example.
A grappling.
Yeah, that's going to be new.
It's like a gummy ham.
Do you know the ones you throw at the wall?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, look.
Wait, wait, can you like grapple anywhere, like in the sky?
You see that?
So you just grapple in the air like Widowmaker and pull out
your bell.
Oh, it's so much sleeper than me.
Headshot.
Play the game.
While exploring towns, traversing levels, or running through
the wild, you might spot platforms or objects marked with
sticky amber.
Oh, so that's how you do it.
So that's what they're grappling.
I thought they were really just grappling air.
She can even pull or drag items around with it.
It's super versatile.
Who's putting amber on boxes?
Like, it's just like some guy was very stiff.
Sticky hands.
I have that ability.
She can go anywhere she wants.
Oh no, you are.
She's just grappling everywhere.
You see that?
Like, because there wasn't Amber there.
There was an Amber there.
I think those are for like auto aiming.
Using the Sticky Claw ability, grapple your way past
obstacles at high speed.
Swing toward the finish line.
That's like fast travel.
You can nab the top spot.
Get ready, Silas.
Let's see who's got the best moves when version 2.0 drops.
Oh, I do.
Next, we have an ability.
that's big.
Gigantification.
Deep in Elderwood Forest lives across massive creatures.
We imagine the fur pelts.
Oh my god.
Imagine the jacket that you can make out of this guy.
The Uggs.
Oh, they're gonna...
Oh, it's...
Oh, wait!
I told you guys, imagine the outfit.
You're the outfit, yeah.
Fun fact, when Nikki uses the gigantic...
ability her size increases by more than three oh my gosh she
finally went from 5.9 to 6.1 511 to 6 foot yeah it's crazy
identify she can also unleash a thunderous roar so also
unlock a charge skill that will allow her to sweep across an
entire battlefield with oh my gosh she's just find giant
folders apparently like the longer you play I was reading it
the longer you play the bigger you get what I was gonna be
oh my god it's gonna be like a kaiju fight who did you kill
for this outfit battle companion ability I wonder.
It looks like a dragon.
It does.
Like a furry dragon.
Yeah.
Reporting for duty.
You know, in certain areas of version 2.0, Nikki can summon
Phantom Queen.
Oh, I have like pillow pets too.
Oh, so this is like a summoner.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Nikki won't be fighting alone anymore.
And those are the four plans.
Oh, we're going to have friends.
In version 2.0.
So you can have friends fight for me.
archery bringing style and finesse along with a new form of
combat sticky claw allowing niki to grapple from one
location to the next cute gigantification i wonder if you
because you know how like you can change specific outfits
like pieces of it i wonder like if you have like all
different pieces of each outfit well you have all the
abilities with these new abilities yeah i wonder if you have
to a full set or not yeah or yeah it has to be a full set of
course ability outfits and their abilities aren't bound to
each other which means stylists are free to dress nikki
however yeah oh good good okay nice nice because i want to
sleep yeah oh my god feels like we're the pre-recorded ones
we're the pre-recorded video do the pre-recorded video yeah
i set that up Hmm.
The ancient legends of this land, tales of gods and their
deeds remain shrouded in mystery.
Meanwhile, the mysterious task entrusted to Nikki served as
a subtle guide, both a warning and a hint of what is yet to
come.
Without further ado, let's take a short break and move on to
the next round of today's giveaway.
Oh, another giveaway for us.
I'm so excited.
All right, let's go over the rules one more time.
Stylus, all you have to do is type archery in the chat.
Archery, guys.
Guys, guys, archery in chat, guys.
Type archery in chat to be injured to this giveaway.
Disclaimer, you might not win.
Disclaimer, the five was put in on accident.
There's not supposed to be a five.
Disclaimer, maybe no one will win, but we don't know that.
If you could choose one of Nikki's four new abilities in
real life, which one would you choose?
Ooh!
I think it would be a gigantic vacation for me.
Why?
Why not?
I mean, it's lame, but like, I want to be amazing at
archery.
I want to, I think for me, yeah, I was going to say the
sticky cloud would be fun.
Well, you know what?
You know why I would choose sticky cloud?
Well, let me, you know what?
We're running out of time.
Three, two, one.
Okay, stylist.
at the end of our second round of giveaways the list of
winners will be pinned in the comments and shared on our
official social check the comments guys also like why would
you want archery just pick up a bow you don't need the
outfit just bows are real no man no man listen but i suck at
everything i thought that doesn't work it's not does not
exist in real life but you can literally grab my size the
government is going to dissect me the government will be
like well how are you doing this gonna like waterboard me
and stuff if i'm just really good amazing archer then like
they're like oh she's just based yeah oh she just she's just
a prodigy yeah exactly if i like run around like sticky
claws in my hand and like going big and small and summoning
demons they're gonna like wait a minute how's she doing this
oh oh there's all the dead dragons yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Those are all the dead dragons she killed for her outfit.
Oh my gosh, she's ready.
She's like, guys, I got this.
What can we do with this guy?
They're like, I killed her mom to make this beautiful dress.
And I want another one.
So I'm going to raise this one up.
I get a matching purse.
Oh.
she's where the dragon was oh my god what did she do with
the what did she do with the dragon did she take its place
well I guess what happened to the baby dragon did she make
it to purse yet what happened to it ma'am she's gonna melt
the skills I'll dab it up grab her hand grab that dangerous
hand Oh my god, those shoes are beautiful.
They're so pretty.
Good night.
Oh?
Oh!
Oh, wait, she got teleported.
She checked an enderperl.
Like, how did she get here?
Oh, pretty.
Was she locked in?
Oh, they both were, like, grabbed a hand.
Oh, my!
Oh!
Oh, my god!
This is cute!
They're best friends.
Oh, my god.
their outfits changing oh my gosh wait wait oh my gosh she
went gothic they're both emo they're both emo now oh my gosh
they were roommates guys they're their best friends oh oh
Oh my gosh, that's so cute.
Welcome back.
Those outfits are so gongous.
These are the two Danny five-star.
Did she say gongous?
I thought he was saying it.
These outfits are so gongous.
I was just like, wait a minute, Saturday.
No, wait.
I mean, she's right.
They are gongous.
They are so gongous.
really meant it's like gigantic gorgeous they're so funny
i'm gonna start using that that's conscious girl oh my love
is so content oh my god reflecting the choices of fate in
different direction now this theme of common origins yet
divergent destinies lies at the very heart of these two i
read that book divergent when faith collapses and prayers go
unanswered do we yield to the or rise to challenge fate
itself.
With that question in mind, let's take a closer look at the
details of these outfits.
Let's start with the Divine Maiden.
Oh, Divine Maiden.
We have so many inspirations for like new outfits with this
game.
What is stopping us from dressing like this every day?
Besides time.
Okay, like we nearly talked about it.
And functionality.
solitary okay i'll stop the outfit is primarily a soft
golden hue with the skirt draped and delicate sumptuous oh i
love gemstones that must be so heavy though on that head i
know her head is probably yeah and intricate detailing the
ensemble radiates folk sanctity i'm surprised she could keep
her head up the makeup design is equally exquisite imagine
how much Money and makeup they've like used every day.
Every day.
That's not cheap shit, too, that you buy at the...
That's like Mac.
That's like good stuff.
Yeah, that's the good shit.
The ones you have to get imported in Japan.
Oh, yeah.
Or like K-beauty.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They got snail use.
Actually, so I was like, actually, that's a natural look.
Oh, yeah, it's just a Loki natural.
Yeah, natural look.
No makeup.
Hashtag no makeup.
No filters.
offering herself times and not even filters guys salvation
how do i lock this guy the first evolution of the outfit
adopts a serene just woke up like i like this one a lot more
this one is gorgeous oh yeah because some of the outfits
yeah but that was level one though shadow a dark aura
cloaking her entirely that one's pretty even the last
glimmer of hope yeah you can like you can basically
customize like the colors and design there has to be a happy
ending don't not everyone has a Happy ending, girl.
This is the real world.
Animals get skinned and dragons lose their whole...
Oh my god, fur is very so soft.
I want it.
I want it as my minions.
Good thing these outfits aren't flammable.
Yeah.
I mean, we can find out now.
Oh, guys, I don't know now.
Aw!
She, I think the outfits are been flammable.
Wait, no.
Oh, she got old, her hair turned white.
Oh, pretty.
Ooh, shadow the hedgehog.
Wow, so this is the outfit's third evolution.
Behind prayer, silent ashes.
Rose petals whirl.
This one's really pretty, but funnily enough, I really like
level one.
The white one?
The white one, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
The Divine Maiden lives on, returning in a blaze of
vengeance.
Wow, I'm impressed.
I had no idea.
Oh yeah, it's like Gothic Lolita.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just noticed.
The very princess's new colors are deep black and dark
crimson, with the skirt adorned in rubies and delicate
beaded chains.
Oh.
Oh, rubies.
Oh my gosh.
That's an expensive ass outfit if it's adorned with rubies.
Yeah, girl, don't slam your dress on that one.
Well, I'm gonna like, I'm gonna steal the dress and just
pick out the rubies.
Grab some scissors and just go snip snip.
Yeah, I'm gonna like trip in front of her.
I'm gonna trip in front of her and start picking out her
dress.
Yeah.
And they're like, oh man, are you okay?
You're just like, you're just like grabbing the rubies.
She's there exponentially into the fate itself.
The outfit- Dude, her crown alone can pay for like my red
for the next 20 years.
And dress option.
Stylists can decide whether to wear the veil, tweak the
skirt length and craft a look that's entirely their own.
And when stylists reach 160 poles, they'll unlock the
exclusive decoration, Sanctum of Heart.
Oh, you unlock a cage.
You unlock a cage and lock yourself in.
The storytelling is simply unmatched.
Not only that, glowing up the outfit will also unlock a new
color variant.
The dark green hues combined with her golden hair oh i like
that one as she might have been oh that's true i think the
jewels are emerald too in that moment she still held on to
hope praying she could bring hope back to her people back
before she like back when she said light in her eyes before
the trauma kicked in as some of you may have guessed the
outfit expands upon nikki's new sticky claw or grappling
ability with this outfit she has a new held item a golden
cage which is home to a tiny enchanting dragon when
activated oh so like her grappling is like with the dragon
makes flight yeah straight toward her target oh so like
there's other outfits with abilities too out of her tower
venturing she's parkoring in this outfit parkour nicky can
follow the golden light while gliding oh that's really
strong forward like a star across the sky and if nikki
pauses in midair stylists are in for a treat a golden
platform forms beneath her feet oh so she can make her own
platform wait that's this outfit is so strong what the heck
oh my god where you get over here oh my gosh take your
friends along oh yeah because it's multiplayer guys that's
not all this outfit oh that's that's your mom that's not me
i well i haven't seen her a while oh huge boost in
efficiency however are you like still staying with grandma
that the outfits yeah yeah i'm staying in the guest room
don't worry i'll be back with milk i know i'll see you in a
month yes
yet it really leaves a little bit of a heavy feeling the
divine maiden who would tell such a story must have carried
so much suffering and I agree.
Now, if someone's like, can you drop your friend asking for
a friend?
I'll just be like, take my hand in the outfit and I'll take
you like all the way up.
And then and then and then the strand.
I'll leave you strand in the middle of the forest.
Drop it on an enemy.
Oh yeah, drop you into like some boss stage is like, here
you go.
You can be an Uber in multiplayer worlds.
Charge people?
Ooh, the bag is...
Oh, yeah, you're right.
It pays itself.
It's gonna be like, invite me, you need an Uber.
I got this outfit.
I got the fast travel outfit.
Exactly.
The core concept of this outfit revolves around scars and
light.
The her destiny lies in ruins.
Oh.
Their body bears countless scars.
Each mark...
But that was the outfit in the intro.
You remember it?
Like a tutorial?
her passive wounds haven't blessed her divinity they've
become a unique tapestry of strength and radiance the makeup
design adds a final enchanting touch perfectly extenuating
the outfit's delicate oh cute i like that her face is
adorned this is one of my favorites i really like uh the
vastness of the universe while a soft starlight glimmers in
her eyes i like how like detailed all like the Starlight
glimmers and my little pony character.
Did you know that?
I'm sorry.
That's why you left this.
The base version of Born Plolus actually includes two
different designs for the headwear and the back.
I like the small details that they do for the outfit to
enhance, like even the smallest thing.
Oh, there's something!
Oh, the pendant details.
Look at the glitter.
Oh, I want to eat that outfit.
Oh, that's cute.
Color palette to vibrate.
Oh, he's like green, too.
Compromises by warmth and warmth.
Good observation.
There's like the different colors you can pick for it.
It's not just blue.
I like the orange hair.
Oh, the red.
Wow.
The blood of your enemies.
Yes.
Oh, I really like the black face, like the face makeup.
That's cool.
From the vibrant green of new beginnings to the steadfast
red of resolve, what hue will the third evolution adopt when
the saintess bears the weight of her ultimate destiny?
evolution and see for ourselves.
Wait, Chibi, I just noticed you have horns.
What?
You have horns.
Sorry, I have a horn.
You had horns.
It's okay, don't worry.
I'll make sure to be...
I'll make good use of it.
Don't turn them into like a backscrap or something.
This is why I come back every couple of months because the
horns grow back and...
Dude, like, that is hard to stick me.
Daddy's got a new client that needs those horns.
So what if someone commissioned another freaking set of
heels?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like, get over here.
Get over here, Chad.
That's like outer space.
It's like cosmic.
Wow.
Impressive, isn't it?
This is the outfit's third evolution, born flawless,
mirrored self.
The outfit is cloaked in a profound, inky black, while the
hem radiates a pure white glow, like light piercing through
darkness.
Scattered across her form.
Oh, I guess it's like the final evolution of the outfit.
Oh, Maria Barat Malice.
Every shift of the life.
It looks like her makeup has changed as well.
The mark on her forehead is more defined.
And her eyes are deeper and more determined.
They're more glittery.
Yeah, like crystallized.
Oh, my God, you could take it off.
Oh, oh, there's, yeah, you could take off like the sweeping
thing.
Yeah, like if it's getting your feet, you can get a lot.
I'm a long dress, you can make it shorter.
totality to the ensemble now when that's nice i like the
variations 60 polls a 30-second exclusive dance animation
will be unlocked oh wait she's dead oh i want to see this so
yeah like i so my chat was like yeah she's ready to go
clubbing oh it's interpretive oh it's interpretive her story
fly with that outfit too and this this outfit has everything
she's telling her story
boo look at her girl majestic
beautiful god was it gongous wow she looks absolutely
stunning this dance shows the saintess reconciling with her
shattered self i'm sure everyone can feel her inner strength
through it now finally there's the exclusive color scheme
unlocked once the outfit has been glowed up amid countless
endless nights i like that term glowed up i just think doing
laundry oh oh all gold but i was gonna say like how do you
wash this like how do you do it like one use the atmosphere
creates is nothing you wear for one night and that's over
she looks so beautiful i own a lot of really fancy dresses
and you actually don't wash them a lot you just make sure
you're super clean yeah make sure you don't wear it for too
long this outfit yeah because like the wash you need to do
certain like temperature of water you gotta do it by hand
and let it dry it's a lot on nikki's right hand index finger
rests a gleaming crystal clear ring within which oh i like
that it's like the archer but this ring harnesses oh yeah
she's Conjuring radiant light She stands over Yeah Only
nerds are magic users Her combat style flows in harmony With
the theme of fate Yeah we're not nerds We're cool Yeah we're
cool like that Shaping the battle Yeah Nice by the way It's
not because we're It's not because we're Too stupid to learn
magic We're just too cool for school We were actually fluent
in magic We just Yeah Because we're cool Yeah we're just You
know We could learn Like look Look I can gumbo gumbo my eyes
Nikki's ultimate skill I know magic but I just don't do it I
don't think that's magic I think that's a medical concern
I just don't see it just don't seize and that's it star
resonance outfits what do you think Alina hmm it looks like
the saintess didn't take the same destroy everything rude
the divine maiden did I wonder if there are any hidden
surprises then again the divine maiden is a character the
saintess herself created maybe she poured some of her own
and spooky feelings into the divine maiden things she
couldn't say out loud which makes me even wonder Did
DeSantis really never doubt herself, not even for a second?
That's a very interesting question.
As for the truth behind these two outfits, let's leave it to
the stylist to uncover as they experience them in the game.
Now, let's move on to the...
Yeah, no spoilers.
You gotta download the game to find out more.
Join the giveaway.
Yeah.
Okay, click on the link, put it in our chat so you want to
check it out and figure out why I like this one.
Exclamation point, Nikki.
I like this accent.
like a priestess yeah yeah with a book in her hand i always
think like this type of aesthetic is really cute such a
dignified style when nikki activates her ability yeah oh
like a bard kind of yeah a soft melodic chant golden notes
and feathers drift through the air casting a serene ethereal
life he's basically a bard oh i like that guy in the back
yeah he's jamming out that's right Little does he know, I'm
coming for him.
Little does he know his legs will be harvested.
Yeah, little does he know I'm...
The song was just a bait.
They cut away because we started, like, taking him.
Oh, cute!
I like the swoop.
Oh, yeah, it's like a belly dancing.
He shared the same banner as Born Flawless.
It's like the Pied Piper.
You know, I lured the rats in with my song.
Oh, yeah, dude.
The entire ensemble glimmer is getting captivated in the
way.
It's like, mama needs a new jacket.
You could just spread joy wherever she goes.
The outfit's ability is even more playful.
When activated, here's the diaper chat.
Get it.
Wait, none of the other mush kids are wearing diapers.
Like, what's wrong with this mushroom?
Oh, I like the black.
He's a little special.
Also, I like the black version of that.
Yeah, I like the blue hair.
Guys, there can't be only one mushroom baby.
There has to be more.
I'm not even kidding.
This has been so entertaining.
I've been so locked in.
I'm not even kidding.
I've been so into this.
I just like seeing all the different outfits.
I love folding designs.
Yeah, the designs are so pretty.
The resonance banner outfits.
There are plenty more outfits coming to version 2.0.
In fact, another very important reason Nikki's journey to
Itzalan is to discover new miracle outfits.
And as she unravels the secrets of this region, she stumbles
upon clues that point her toward the miracle outfit,
Providence in Memorial.
By completing the main storyline quest in version 2.0,
stylists will unlock all the sketches for Providence in
Memorial, allowing them to obtain this exquisitely stunning
outfit in its entirety.
Now, let's take a look at the PV for the new miracle outfit
outfit, the Providence in Memorial.
Oh?
Oh, another new outfit for the anniversary.
Oh, pretty.
Oh, the shoes.
Oh, the gloves, though.
You can...
Those are sharp gloves.
You can scratch someone with that.
I think this one's my favorite.
I'm a really big fan of, like, cool gloves.
I still think the, what was it, the dreamy one?
That one's still my favorite.
it this one's my favorite because it's like it's almost like
a knife oh that's true yeah i love all the black
alternatives like color that designs that's really pretty
the contrast yeah she looks so majestic with the black oh we
know what to do with these one for each of us oh yeah oh
true true oh we already got one of those we're eating good
tonight oh wait oh the whole family make a whole that would
make the entire set with the whole family you know yeah like
honestly yeah we're we're not separating them exactly if
it's only it's it's good to get rid of them all so then
they're not sad yeah you know and they can still be together
they're all in one set oh
oh it's a dragon oh wait they're taking her back wait is she
the dragon yeah remember
Because like the other girl was the Was the Other blue hair
girl I like her That's it Providence and Memorial It's okay
I didn't even try saying it Because I knew it was like I was
gonna pull All about to pull a gongous That's so gongous
She's so gongous Oh I like that one Oh mine was the red one
was my favorite The red or the black one default one the
most the starter hmm pretty who invited these guys they're
awesome what do you mean i like oh it's like they're in the
back to make you look even more pretty you know i'm oh my oh
yeah no the default yeah default's cute they put the
mushrooms in the back to highlight how much prettier she is
than them oh you know that's an ugly friend yeah yeah yeah
yeah why do you think It's because they're all Tokis.
I got a TV Toki and it made me look fat.
Me, the other Toki look a little better.
What are you talking about?
I'm commanding, radiating an unscathed aura of divinity.
Hey, circle at this.
Okay, you might be the...
Are you laughing?
My mom's kind of homeless.
Please, Toki, I need this.
Radiating a divine presence.
if a deity has arrived.
As Nikki pursues this miracle outfit, she'll face new and
unexpected situations, and we can't wait for stylists to
experience them firsthand.
Talking about all these outfits really leaves you wanting
more.
And these three five-star outfits in particular, they're so
impressive.
What about you, stylist?
How do you feel about them?
Of course, that's not everything coming your way in version
2.0.
Oh, there's more?
New features and stories.
See, you got that from my me.
But wait.
There's more.
Why don't we take a little break and do another round of
giveaway for the show?
Guys, we're doing another giveaway, guys.
I'm going to walk in.
Lock in, guys.
So the rules are just like before.
After we count down to one.
If you type Terra's call, you might win another $50 gift
card.
Terra's.
Now we randomly select 10 dollars to receive a $50 cash
reward.
typo in that fifty dollars the five is cosmetic it's not
actually we won't tell you which number is which number it
is take a screenshot of your youtube id and send your
contact information to the designated email to claim your
prize all right let's get started three two one start let's
go these two outfits were based on the characters the
saintess and the divine maiden i want to ask you which
character do you think you're more like i would say divine
maiden really you don't seem really convinced he's just like
are you are you stupid like what about you guys want to know
which character i'm more like yeah okay well let me tell you
a story because it's oh actually we're running out of time
three two one that's funny every time congratulations to our
lucky winners and wishing yeah he's definitely reading her
It's like, girl, girl, you'll be the mushroom with the
diaper.
That's right.
So aside from our brand new, girl, you're the mushroom in
the group.
And brand new ability.
We are also bringing Silas plenty of exciting standalone
dungeons.
Oh, when I gave them one, they said they won the giveaway.
Oh my god, wait, wait a minute.
Five of six of my viewers won.
Wait, let's go, guys.
Mother Shroom's dream.
Remember there's 10 that's picked.
dungeon brings its own unique style and gameplay filled with
countless surprises just oh ganges let's take a look at our
first dungeon mother shroom's dream stop trying to make
ganges happen this is a ganges moment mushrooms of all
shapes and sizes emit a gentle enchanting glow creating a
magic wait where do we see who would okay i have the list
right here in my hand
Yeah, we're doing another giveaway, you guys.
Type Gondas.
They will lead you in the right direction.
And doesn't a mother shroom's dream mean that deep within
the dungeon, secrets about the mother shroom are waiting to
be uncovered.
It means we harvest the entire family to make this outfit.
Oh, you get a buff if it's the whole thing.
The second dungeon takes us deep into Elderwood Forest,
where the foreboding Colosseum awaits.
This dungeon is a remnant of the ancient Titan civilization.
countless relics from a long forgotten era lie in quiet
repose though shrouded in dust they stand as silent
witnesses to a bygone age offering stylists a glimpse of the
once magnificent glory check the she-con jewel the
shrewlings near the coliseum said what is going on peaceful
lately they can hear strange noises yeah i'm scared i don't
think this door is not holding him I don't think this door's
gonna hold him out.
He's kind of weak, actually.
I'm actually not breaking that.
Yeah, I'm not that scared.
That door not broken yet.
Is he declawed?
Don't declaw your monsters, guys.
Unless you can make fashion.
Yeah, because unless it's for fashion, unless it's...
Unless you can put them on your own nails.
Yeah.
Then it's awesome.
It also means that the vault is heavily guarded.
with traps everywhere.
Oh.
And alarms go off.
Why don't we just leave the monsters in here?
It's like, it's like a farm.
Now, did any, like a skeleton farm?
Yeah, like a, like a mob spawn.
Yeah, a mob farm.
This is where stylists can really take advantage of Nikki's
posing for the cameras while she's robbing.
Yeah.
It can be like a master cat burglar and slip past all the
criminals.
It's up to you.
I have a crush.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, true, true, true.
police of course i mean what would it's a crime to have all
this jewels locked up our new eslings are unmistakably from
this land their unique designs exuding the lively spirit of
the forest why are they so unhappy each have a unique
appearance because they don't have like my shoes oh that's
true own special trait for example the earthbound wolfhead
will break into a dance commanding its minions to form a
coordinated formation around its own cute Oh, I want to eat
these guys.
Intense version of certain Esalenes.
If you run into one of them in the wild, you'll need to
stand high alert.
Those are nice feathers.
They'll go great with my hat.
I love the way you're thinking.
I know, right?
But too bad for them.
Now, Nikki is the best sharpshooter in all of Italy.
These Esalenes, Nikki will wipe them out without even
breaking a sweat.
And finally, Nikki and Momo will face their toughest
challenge yet.
a battle atop the very peak of Spira.
This time, things are a bit different.
Stylists will discover that the environment constantly
changes, delivering a dynamic and unique battle experience
like never before.
The battle unfolds in stages, with each phase introducing
brand new mechanics and puzzles.
Oh, there's like parkour.
Yeah.
Moving at just the right moment to overcome the many
obstacles that Oh, that's true.
As the battle progresses, Stylos will encounter...
Or like a pendant friend.
Oh, no!
Bebe, bebe, bebe, bebe, so boots.
Every decision is crucial.
And victory...
I feel like I could use, like, you know, like the hands?
Or like a cape.
Ooh!
That'd be a nice cape.
This boss battle will be a piece of cape for Nikki.
With their newly unlocked abilities, it will be like...
Does he have scoliosis?
I did.
All right.
I feel represented.
He just wanted to be represented.
Look, there's you in the game.
Fun stuff coming your way in version 2.0.
Oh, what's the rush?
I mean, we still have plenty of time.
So before we do that, let's take a little break.
It's almost December, and you know what that means.
That's right.
The holiday season is almost upon us.
That's why we are bringing you a little holiday update from
Nikki and Momo.
So let's take a look and see what these two have planned for
the holiday.
for the holidays, Nikki and Momo's holiday plan.
Now they've worn eat.
Okay.
Don't they like live next to each other?
Can't they just talk to each other?
Maybe they're like in bed and they won't get up.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
I was gonna be like... Oh, Slee, look at that.
Oh.
The WPM on these texts is insane.
But these guys are fast.
Bro, I can't even Do you have the full set or something?
Like, what's out there five minutes?
Nikki just grows like 10 hands.
Yeah, they actually have like 20 fingers.
She's like typing with her feet like an organ player.
And also with her hands.
Looks like Nikki and Mama are settling into its land just
fine.
I agree.
Along the way, they'll meet lots of new friends and explore
exciting, brand new gameplay experiences unique to this
region.
a brand new gameplay aspect to our stymie faction oh in
version 2.0 what's the new gameplay factions are getting a
major upgrade a brand new deduction mechanic adds depth to
these organizations unlocking even more faction related wait
join my faction the dokeyberg faction i haven't made it yet
but join it it's awesome because it's a dokey dokey bird
stands for chibi dokey right yeah yeah yeah yeah so you're
sort of like part of it too awesome dude i feel so included
wild i look forward to seeing nikki take him on in a styling
duo let's take a look at some of the collections stylists
can find in itzalan scattered across elderwood forest and
spira are the mysterious crystals blessing yeah 1v1 me in
fashion challenges to collect and assemble these crystals oh
i love the cute little hat rewards and gaining a deeper
understanding of the god's past along the way oh nikki look
down harvest that guy engage in battles and even dash
through parkour sequences oh my dude am i cleaning it he can
even transform well yeah i gotta make sure the hair is like
good so whenever oh that's true yeah because you don't want
to get blood on it too using her abilities nikki can purify
and collect all oh it went from 2 3d to 2d this will also
uncover the secrets of frogs explore a chapter of history
long bird in the past Oh, there's exposition time.
New box games exclusive to Itzalan.
Behemoth Beater and Grass Glaster.
The first game puts her reflexes to the test as you face off
against mighty behemoth.
Oh, you'd be good at this one because you're like a big
gamer.
Peer away weed.
Watching the field gradually tidy up.
Oh, is this just pinball?
Oh, this pinball.
You'd be good at this game because it's for children.
And that's what happened on the major new game was you're
just coming your way in version 2.0.
rewards so now let's see what i actually really suck in
ballards i think my daddy kicks with my we're kicking off a
five-day countdown event starting today and running through
november 25th oh oh your mom's new boyfriend right yeah yeah
yeah allowing them to collect a total of 300 diamonds by the
end of the event we've also got some goodies for you to mark
the one year anniversary of infinity nikki starting december
4th you think We'll be giving stylists a total of 10
residences.
So it's like pinballs for everyone.
Oh, she said we're gonna give each stylist a total.
I thought she said each stylist a turtle and I got excited.
I was like, I'm getting a turtle?
Like a little turtle assistant.
He holds all your makeup brushes.
As always, we've prepared exclusive rewards for our version
2.0.
Oh, use these codes!
Yeah, guys, we're gonna use these codes.
Yeah, yeah.
No anniversary celebration would be complete.
without a special who's talking to us who's i think it's
nikki the five star set of clothes radiant crown completely
free this set of clothes embodies rebirth and hope oh it's
free i love free stuff warm steadfast and radiant guiding
the way forward with gentle yet unwavering light i like this
color way yeah it's like a nice it's just so pure yeah It's
so pure and it's something I can never be.
So I want it.
What?
That's a sentence.
Guys, clip that.
Nikki has too much blood.
I want something I can obtain.
By the way, Alina, did you know that there's a very special
day coming up really, really soon?
What's that special day?
Christmas.
Santa Claus?
Over the past year, Nikki has traveled to new places, made
new friends, and experienced so much along the way.
Let's take a moment to look back on this journey together as
we enjoy the PV for Nikki's birthday celebration.
Yay!
It's her birthday.
Oh, it's because there's birthday soon.
It's in December.
Where's the whale?
Bring in the whale.
Oh, yeah, we saw the whale.
Oh, yeah, we saw this, guys.
You guys missed out.
If you guys download the game right now, you can play the
beautiful intro.
get the ride of whale yeah you get to ride a whale it was so
cool and there were like dolphins everywhere in the sky and
then a woman held her hands it was real it was real it
happened she held her hands oh i love the hair oh i think i
like this one yeah this one is good i like it yeah if you
click the link and download the game right now a woman will
hold your hand and you can feel like dance and stuff yeah
and you get to dance too Oh, dude, you get to make a wish.
Me?
I'm the best stylist ever?
Thanks, guys.
I really feel good about myself now.
Yeah, me too.
That's like the prettiest outfit I've seen.
I like this one the most.
For sure.
Oh, like the dress is such a cute length.
Yeah.
As soon as I love it.
Guys, on December 6th, you get to claim the birthday gift.
So these are all free, I believe.
Yeah.
All of these.
ugly friend.
Nikki looked really pretty in that shot.
I don't know why.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When she was there with those, with my friends, she looked
so pretty.
With those peasants that didn't have this outfit.
She looked so pretty around them for some reason.
Nikki, you're the best stylist.
Nanoi, Gerota, Rambi, and so many others.
All these memories are coming back.
The moment Nikki stands in the starlight, sword in hand,
moving forward, it's incredibly moving.
I love this outfit.
I would wear that.
It's really one of a kind.
That's right.
Like, in battle?
Or like, like, outside?
Like at Walmart.
At Walmart.
You know, like, those people, if you see videos of those
people, like, in old Victorian dresses, And he, like,
dressed that every day.
By simply logging in, you can claim it for free.
Yeah, December 6, guys.
Remember.
She comes with a stylus.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh.
So, you get it.
I still like the Difa.
More.
The red makes her look more badass, though, I will admit.
Yeah.
Like a battle.
Yeah, like battle ready.
White-based and layered.
I like this version more.
Oh, yeah.
The socks are cute.
Golden accents add delicate details.
I like all the earrings though.
I like the earrings.
If you run too fast, then it stabs you in the neck.
That's true, yeah.
Do you have earrings?
Do you wear earrings?
No, I don't have any piercings.
Me too, I don't either.
I was too scared to do it when I was young and then I got
too scared today.
I cry when I get shots.
I don't like the like stab.
Like, and then you heard like people who do get piercings,
they can get ear infections.
easily too yeah if you don't clean it yeah i don't mess with
that of course what's a birthday celebration without
birthday rewards right i'm not wearing i'm not actually
wearing earrings but these are clip-ons oh yeah i have
clip-ons yeah i have clip-ons right now these are clip-ons
for further details be sure to keep in i never noticed your
pointy ears yeah makes sense yeah that's where you don't
worry your mom your mama's head so fat features and generous
rewards and for all our stylists in europe and north america
the fun doesn't stop there but before we talk about that
let's review all the goodies waiting for stylists in version
2.0 during version 2.0 in addition to the one five earn
rewards worth 126 draws and 50 sets of new clothes for free
whoa and a free way you get a free house what the heck you
got what guys you get a free house that's that's more than
enough but i want a free house i so read and from just
exploring it's a it's an apartment i was with my mom and my
my elder dad altogether that's a total of 15 brand new sets
of clothes yes you should you should get on the uh infinity
nikki right now so you can get that free house for them
joining the various version but yeah he's like mom i got us
a house it's in game but it's a free i'll get them vr
headsets just close your eyes and pretend that's real yeah i
think mom dad i got us a free house put this on just put
this on yeah in addition to celebrate the launch of version
2.0 we've prepared a lot of pop-up events nikki will use her
ability outfits to turn the world into a time squid what is
this oh it was guys oh wait it's today today to go it's go
fly to new york guys guys go to new york right now to see
look your flights from november 26th to november 30th you
can catch nikki and momo yeah nikki buildings on the streets
of nighttime london try out the sticky and london too look
on the state of new york and then london in new york and
help a Gigantified Nikki find Momo at Paris Westfield Forum
Deale.
And of course, Nikki cosplayers will be popping up for you
to find and take photos with.
Oh, that's cute.
Okay, going to the airport right now.
Earning exclusive rewards and making plenty of precious
memories along the way.
This series of themed events has already been shared on
social media, so Stylis, don't miss your chance to join in.
Wow, talk about world colliding.
in London and Paris.
I wish I could be there to join in on the fun.
Time flies, and today's preview live stream of version 2.0
has already come to an end.
A huge thank you to every stylist who has been with us on
this journey so far.
The moment the stream ends, they'll be gone forever, guys.
This might be a city into our world full of whim and wonder.
Version 2.0 marks the dawn of a brand new friend.
They were raised for this moment.
Yeah.
They were raised.
They were grown organically in our farm.
in our lab just for this moment and now they will be
harvested for clothing that's why all of us here on the
infinity nicotine are always working always improving and
always finding ways to move forward once again a big thank
you to all of the stylists for your support and
encouragement don't worry all ethical or all organic guys
you were raised They were raised on.
Free range.
Free range, guys.
Oh, the Eat the Bag is so cute though.
Aww.
I push a lot of cash.
Yeah, that's true.
I was like, card holder, Momo Eat the Bag, cash.
Also, our version 2.0 content creator program is on the way.
We're calling out to all the creative stylists out there.
This is your chance.
Join the program to unlock exclusive rewards and even more
surprises.
Follow us so you don't miss the sign-up details when they
drop.
And last but not least, Twitch drops for version 2.0 are
coming soon.
Watch any participating streamer and Queen Wars as you go.
Not really, but like...
It could be.
It could be us.
And memories of Wishfield from this last year will become
more than just memories.
They'll serve as a guiding light leading Nikki and Momo
forward.
So let us accompany them on this new adventure as they make
their way the dawn of it's the land and with that our
version 2 oh it is us oh we have twitch drops right now
jimmy it is us guys we have twitch drops guys guys keep
watching we have to get those drops guys we actually do have
twitch yeah if you want to be a cute girl that is us and i
have a couple for infendi nikki's 2.0 update first i wish
that everyone has all the bling they need and
be able to get every outfit don't worry i know you will i'm
also wishing that a certain character makes a return i also
wish that more people are going to learn about she's a fan
and join us on our styling journey but those are only some
of my wishes oh here's for you wishing for infinity nikki's
2.0 update hi stylists i'm vampia and i wanted to be 2.0 of
infinity nikki oh she has do you see she has monster high
dolls behind her i noticed that i actually really like
monster a community that is so passionate, creative,
helpful, and, of course, fashionable.
You, this game, and everything in it, fill me with so much
inspiration, and I can't wait to see what you and I create
from here on out.
Happy 2.0.
Happy anniversary.
Have you noticed people make hearts like that?
Back in my day, we made the thumbs on the bottom.
Oh, yeah, the thumbs.
I think, like, I'm old.
I've seen those before.
But there's not that easy.
they're okay they're sort of like a bit difficult to make
because it's not comfortable like i'm making it i can't do
the like the zoomer heart i'm doing the heart i don't think
that's the zoomer heart i think it is if you ask a young
person to make a heart with their hands that's how they do
it now not like the one word you know like the old one with
the with the thumbs on the bottom and like yeah yeah that's
how i do it yeah but then there's no and well there's the
other one with the two thumbs the two thumbs it's a small
heart i thought you were talking about that yes yeah And
like, if you ask a young person to go on the phone, they
just, they don't do the pinky and thumb anymore.
They don't do that because they're like, what is that?
They just do text, do texting.
I know.
And there was like this video I watched where like they were
giving a child like, uh, like, like old, old, like 90s, 90
to 80s things.
And then they were like, what is that?
Is that like a computer?
Like they gave them a little, I think it was like a...
Oh, it's sad enough.
Or it's woven into every part of the experience.
that we go i like her glasses like i can't see the frames at
all yeah and honestly i'm so grateful that infinity nikki
exists for all the people who've been looking for a space
that feels like it's made for them so happy one year
anniversary happy 2.0 and here's to many more years of
infinity
Oh my god, the beat dropped.
Hey!
Beat dropped!
Yeah,
throw those light sticks in the air.
Oh!
That's, I did not expect the genre swap there.
It was crazy.
Oh, yeah.
Did you get the link I sent you?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
Did you download it?
Um, I'll get back to you in a second.
Oh, okay.
That is sick.
All right.
So, while, while Chibi is downloading the folder, we did say
we're going to do a little outfit.
review of some of the outfits that you can get uh for the
first year anniversary uh infinite niki so yeah okay let me
know when you have it downloaded chibi there's a lot the
folder has this oh you just click download folder download
all yeah boom yay or can i just can i just like show them
can i just like keep my google drive open and show through
that oh yeah you can do that yeah Yeah, I think that might
be easier, so they're all in one place.
I'll do that.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Okay, so I'm going to show it one by one because I didn't
set anything up for that.
I have too many things on my tabs.
All right, you see the one where it says like, where it's
like with the, like her or the dog?
With the dog.
What's the dog doing?
Yeah, what's the dog doing?
I think mine's organized by name.
Yeah, do by name.
Do by name.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sort by, whimsical word.
Mine start, when it's sorted by name, it has the one with
like, it's like green, yellow, kind of.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the, wait, green, yellow?
Like, it's like a, which has like a mushroom on her head.
Wait, you have the mushroom?
Wait, doesn't yours start with number one?
Okay, Jeevy.
Wait, are you looking at the right folder?
There's folders.
No, no, no.
I said, are you looking?
Okay, the newest link I sent you.
Just click.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, the dog.
Yes, I see it.
You see the dog?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You were not in the right link.
What?
Oh, please.
I am in the right link.
I wish we were.
All right, we're going to do a fashion review now.
This dog has my head.
No, no.
Yours is bigger.
Because, like, you can still... Shut the fuck up.
Your head is bigger than your body.
This dog's head is like, like half the size of his body.
I'm very surprised you can keep your head up and you're not
just like dragging your head while you're walking down the
street.
We're sponsored.
And that's, oh, to be fair, it does make sense because like
in her head there's like no, nothing inside.
So it's like just like air.
So like it's easier to keep it up.
Do you see this cheese on my head?
Yeah.
That's like all the weight that's on it.
you don't want to mess with me what's up with the cheese i'm
a weapon yeah it's like a balloon yeah it's like a balloon
well well you're so lucky to be normally proportioned the
head is like pulling up the entire body
anyway i love the for this outfit i do i think my favorite
i'm sorry my favorite part is the dog The dog makes the
outfit.
Does the dog have like a braid on it?
Wait, does he?
Wait, does.
Did he weave his hair?
I think  no, is that the harness?
No, it's the harness, right?
No, it is.
I think it's like  you know how like grooming?
Oh, yeah, where they shave it down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you see the ones?
Yeah, I saw them like dogs where they like make into a tiger
or something like those puddles.
Yes, it's like dyed rainbow.
Yes, yes, yes.
I do like her ruffled shirt.
Her ruffled shirt's really cute.
Yeah, I like that it's like a crop top.
Yeah, yeah, so these are like free outfits by the way
available in a limited time event So all these outfits will
be obtained that can be obtained for free guys And we all
love free stuff, right?
And you can obtain it right now.
I don't know if it's right now, but you can obtain it soon
You click on the link pin in our chats guys a yo exclamation
point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, supports the stream and the sponsor.
All right, let's go to the flower the next one The spring?
I went to number two.
Oh, you went to number two.
It's the same outfit.
Oh, is it where she's, like, got her hand against her ear?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's just the same outfit, though.
It's just close up, so I feel like we didn't check the other
outfits.
So there's one where she's like, I think it's called, or is
it called spring?
So these would be, this would be an outfit in the store.
I like his cute.
Oh, wait, the one with the orange skirt?
Oh, wait, the long, you mean the dress?
It looks like a skirt with a corset.
Oh.
What?
Or, oh no, are we out of order?
Oh, we're out of order.
I'm like, what are you talking?
Are you not at number four?
I'm on.
Yeah, but number four, number four new outfits in the
moments of spring.
Yeah.
That's not a skirt.
Skirt equal short.
Wait, no, that's not true.
There's long skirts.
No, okay, okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm up with so many skirts.
no no no skirts are short this is what i'm getting rage
baited no no this is a dress is part of the dress but like
this is part of the dress shirts can be long skirts yeah but
you're but they're called maxi skirts a skirt you got okay
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
they're called maxi skirt you didn't say maxi skirt so when
you say skirt you think of the short because that's what
skirts mean i think i think i think you're alone in this one
no no no my chat agrees with me i'm looking at my chat right
now and they all they simping they all said no no what if
your chat's doing that too they hate me they want to like
beat me with hammers so you
but i do like oh i love her hair though and her like little
bonnet oh the braids yeah okay oh and she has freckles too
her makeup's all natural She woke up like that, guys.
Get it, Queen.
Yeah, yeah.
No filter.
Hashtag no filter.
All natural.
And look, she's so beautiful that Momo's crying in jealousy.
Yeah, she's just like, why can't I be just as beautiful as
you?
Oh, my gosh.
The close-up is really pretty.
Number five.
Oh, cute.
The gloves.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you're right.
Oh, the lacy gloves.
Oh, I really love that.
She's so cute.
I used to have this hair color.
Wait, really?
yeah yeah I used to bleach my hair it's still blonde but
it's growing out now yeah yeah the the pink hair is a wig oh
oh okay number six what's number six wait oh oh it's lamo I
don't know if you're still here yeah it's like lilita yeah I
like it I like it too oh I like her little their shoes look
at her shoes they're like oh they look like cake yeah yeah
yeah and Momo actually looks really cute mom was happy now
because she's like i'm just as cute as you now the zoom in
is really pretty i like the layers in the dress that's
really cute yeah i like that too oh there's like a different
color alternative too with uh what is it yeah yeah yeah so
this is a different sweet memories first light these will
all be in the store by the way for the first anniversary so
this is like yellow it looks like a pudding i think yeah
like a fruit cup yeah yeah yeah yeah and then there's
another oh i think i don't know i think i didn't i think the
red one's my favorite it's like a classic christmas yeah
yeah it's like the classic lalita style the colors you know
like the red and gold the yellow i like this one this one's
my favorite guys there's there's a the jellyfish one yeah
yeah i was just looking at that all right i'm gonna show 17.
there's a jellyfish i think this is my favorite so far i
think for me currently it's the oh no there's i see one at
the bottom that i really like it's the you see the the it's
like i think it's so it's um it's the jellyfish but the red
the red one oh the red one yeah yeah 24.
24 is my I think it's like Yeah, yeah, yeah It's almost like
a mushroom looking Yeah Oh, it's like She has mushrooms on
it Yeah, yeah, it's like the classic Glimmering Forest
Twinkle Shroom I didn't know This one's my favorite We go
back Did you see number 22?
That one is cute I like the hair Oh, it's really pretty
Yeah, okay, 22 Oh my God, 21 is evil as hell 21 22 Yeah, she
was looking at this Vampire Dream like night Vampire.
But I don't want to see 21 where she's like in the sky.
Oh, actually, I think the vamp.
Oh, that's so hard to pick because you're all like.
I think the hardest part is that you have your one person.
But I guess you can swap your wardrobe all the time.
But it's so hard to pick your favorite outfit.
This one's really good.
Oh, there's a wedding dress.
You see it?
It's 26.
26.
Oh, I love wedding dresses.
It's so cute.
It's called nameless selfless.
That was called selfless.
So it's like the...
Candle with echoes.
It's like the one where...
Like she's having a great wedding.
And then the next one is like she killed her husband.
And she took the money.
Yeah, she took the...
Yeah, yes!
Yes, you know what?
She's like the heir.
Like she married into like a baron or whatever.
And then the baron slipped and fell down the stairs.
And then she inherited all the money.
and built a fashion empire dude we need to contact the
writers we got the next story for you right here and then 28
she looks like a ghost like she's haunted number 20 dead
wife wait what no 28 28 all right let me see oh yeah she
looks like she's haunting oh yeah yeah and then like she
died and became like a ghost bride but she's still slaying
yeah she's still slaying that's a good yeah yeah Yeah, don't
worry.
She's got a designer down there.
She got a designer ghost to make her dresses.
Oh, heck yeah.
Yeah, and the best part is that, like, they live forever
because they're already dead.
Oh, my gosh.
This is my favorite one, number 30.
Number 30?
The white variant, the white, purple, pink.
Oh, that's cute.
And then she's hiding her other eye because it holds her
powers.
Yeah.
Or she got pink eye.
I don't know.
Oh, well, yeah.
She might have, like, like, like, yeah.
She might have some.
pink guys so she's got to cover it up just too much pink
right i like her shoes her boots are these boots yeah her
boots like the for the wedding they kind of do look like
boots yeah yeah i like that there's so many jewels so it
must be like hell to put all these jewels on like one by one
what else is there oh wait there is a ghost bride 33 that's
literally the ghost bride yes yes i just It's really pretty.
Oh, no.
Where did my picture go?
Up your butt.
We saw.
There you go.
Yeah, this one.
This one looks like a good spread.
Oh, my God.
Look at 34.
34.
Wait, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Look at 36.
36.
Nikki looks really good in this one.
He's like, look at my belly buying.
You mean Momo?
Yeah.
Yeah, Momo.
She's like, she took Momo with her.
She's like, if I'm gonna...
You're coming with me.
We're both gonna be ghosts.
Oh my gosh, I just realized the nameless, nameless, selfless
has so many alternatives.
It is like the...
Oh, yeah, there's 30s.
That is really pretty.
Which one?
Number 37.
I love the colors.
37.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, are these like...
They look like spider legs.
Like...
um ethereal spider legs on the dress yeah this is like the
prettiest outfit wow yeah they have like they have so many
different color variations for this one and then there's the
gold version 40 the ember version yeah that's giving like
queen yeah yeah yeah yeah and finally the last elf wait is
this the last one no never mind the second last outfit is
woodland nesting I like this one's like like princess of
nature yeah yeah oh the Korean one she has like birds on
like her dress you see that bird on her dress like in the
center yeah yeah so sinking they're all like giving her a
hug someone was like when you're dressing up Momo it's like
you're dressing up your cat
was there an emo version?
Oh, there is.
The black one.
Ooh, I think my favorite is actually the blue-green one at
the end.
Blue-green, 47?
Oh, I like that one.
Yeah, it looks really...
47.
Yeah, I like it.
Or, like, yeah, oh, wait, that's 46, guys.
47.
I can't count.
I like that because the dragon's next series, too.
Replace the four with the six.
Anyway, have you checked out 48?
Dream like night.
It's the vampire one, but blue.
Wait, is that?
Yeah, it's the vampire one.
Oh, I didn't even notice that.
You're right.
Oh, cute.
Okay, I like that the vampire one.
Like, she looks like a figure skater now.
Yeah.
Oh, pretty.
I really like that.
I like that too.
It's like not scary anymore.
It's like more elegant.
More elegant.
Yeah, she's like a little ice princess.
Oh.
the oh my god the back design like look at the back yeah i
like that beautiful maiden so yeah guys you could hold their
hands too in the game in the tutorial guys i know if you
download the game right now by clicking our link pin in our
chat in our panel youtube like open world stuff yeah if you
like it's gonna be awesome yeah yeah so it's a whole new
different game compared to like if you tried infinite niki
before um it is very different like the new the new version
of it because it's like oh there's combat open world um and
also like a lot of different abilities and stuff like i saw
like uh there's a quest line too but it's not like linear so
because it is an open world concept there's like uh lots of
like uh different types of main quests and side quests and
all that stuff too um so it's a whole new experience if you
have tried playing playing it before uh you're getting a
whole entirely new experience by trying it checking it out
again for the first year anniversary yeah whether you're a
returning player or a new player it's going to be like a
whole entire fresh experience so if you played it before and
you got burnt out or maybe you want to pick it up again or
you just want to give it a try it's going to be a really fun
experience so I recommend it.
It'll be really fun.
Again thank you so much Infinite Niki for sponsoring us.
Yes thank you and sponsoring both of us too.
yeah so you know i have enough money to pay the child my
child's support again i know she gets all of it so i just
showed up so i could see her yeah like that's part of the
deal i i did visitation yeah yeah yeah like the visitation
fees she has to cheapy has to pay me to for me to see her
yeah celebrity fee it's like a cameo yeah yeah this is my
cameo appearance for it but thank you Eve for sponsoring the
both of us.
We both had a great time watching the live stream preview
and, you know, checking all the new outfits and all the new
features for the first year.
It's the first year anniversary, right?
I can't believe it's been a year old now.
And her birthday's coming up.
Yeah, and her birthday, too.
Yeah.
Christmas, a lot is happening.
Happy early birthday.
Yeah, congratulations on making another year.
Yeah, yeah.
Keep it up.
Thank you guys so much.
me uh chibi are you still in me streaming after this oh i
think i'll talk for like maybe 10 minutes and then and i'm
gonna go lay down i'm getting i i'm tired okay she hurt all
right you can talk to them for 10 more minutes then so
anyway thank you guys again i'm yes thank you so much i'm
gonna head off now so i'm gonna i'm gonna you know give you
guys i'm gonna rate into chibi my daughter would go and be
entertaining you guys for 10 more minutes.
What a gongous idea.
Yeah, so gongous, so gongous there.
But GGs, everyone.
GGs, it was nice to see my kid again.
I can't wait to see you three months.
Yeah, I just can't wait.
But sadly, I have to go out and grab some milk again, Chibi.
So I'll be right back.
You go through a lot of milk.
It's crazy.
Yeah, no, you know, you're not growing, so I'm trying to
figure out what to do.
No matter how milk i give you you're still the size so uh so
i gotta keep restocking milk tv i know thank you you're such
a good dad you know from i know i am a good dad i see i make
an attempt to bond with my child i know like like you know
my name and like you talk to me once a month like you're
like exactly exactly um and like when's your birthday again
it's today oh it's oh happy birthday here is the present yes
i know you i knew i knew i you know i always knew you're
what your birthday was testing you if you remember your
birthday i know if i remember i know yeah yeah i know you
know i just wanted to make sure you remembered you know and
my birthday gift to you is me being here for you not that
your mom forced me or anything but you know no or the
government yeah or the government yeah yeah yeah they sent
me a letter to be like you're not you're not you're supposed
to have her on Sundays and I was like, Sunday is the Lord's
Day.
We kept it near her.
Do you not see the horns on it?
No.
I would like to sincerely thank you for having nothing
better to do than be with me here.
Of course.
Anyway, you know the drill, Chibi.
I gotta get those horns for my client.
All right, here.
Yeah, don't worry.
Don't worry.
All right, God, take those horns.
God, make those new heels.
They're like hot.
telling so hot right now so i know like hotcakes i know i
know every time i visit i gotta grab those horns you know
it's it's good that she grows them back every couple of days
i know it's a really painful transition but it makes my dad
come see me yeah yeah like it's worth the pain you know i
could obviously i could just wait for it to like fall off
like those you know dears whose whose admirers fall off but
like yeah i got the velvet yeah yeah but it ain't the same i
need them fresh you know i know and she gives me like all
these like like these hormones to make them grow even faster
like they do to cows to make them do it and i just snap it
off and be like oh yeah come back in like a month or two i
get a high five every time you got it kiddo you got this
it's like you know it's the top of my dad yeah yeah anything
for your dad right chibi yeah yeah good good job kiddo
you're making me proud here you want to make your dad proud
There you go.
See?
Look at that.
She knows what to do for her old pops.
All right, here.
They were for that for you.
No, there you go.
Oh, two sets.
Look at that.
She cares.
Matching earrings.
Yeah, matching earrings for the boots, you know?
Yeah.
You should probably like it, Dad.
No problem.
You know what?
You want to make Daddy proud.
out right yeah and know what to do that's why i drink now
drink this milky right to help with the growth take your
vitamins take oh yeah yeah yeah take these gummies and
vitamins a lot of bio to make your horns nice and sharp yeah
yeah yeah we gotta make sure those horns grow nice and
strong yeah for daddy's business
anyway and I gotta go buy some more milk now so I'll be back
I'll be back to you thanks for all that bring my birthday no
problem kiddo no problem
tell your mom I said hi and that the and the child support
will come in soon I might be a little late excited yeah yeah
christmas is coming up so i'd like some presents this year
yeah nice oh yeah yeah you don't worry don't worry daddy's
got you a nice present for christmas is it more milk
you'll find out on christmas might be late though it might
be late like last year so like um you know because you know
you know you know your old pops is a very busy man you know
a busy guy yeah yeah i'm like we're all about i'm here
trying to earn a living for you and me and all that child
support so you know we i might be a little late for
christmas maybe like you know a couple of days a couple of
weeks maybe even a couple of months but that's you know
years you know that's normal you know i don't know you know
this but some some like that's normal for dads to like not
be present in your life oh that makes me yeah yeah Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Like, all other dads are just like that, Chibi.
Just so you know, like, a lot of dads are meant to not be
present in your life.
So it'll be okay.
Yeah.
Well, you got, it's like, it's like, you're trying to find
the one piece.
You're just busy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, I'm trying so much, doing so much to, like, to,
you know, provide for us, you know.
I know.
You're such a good guy.
No problem.
No, okay.
Anyway, I need to go get some milk now.
um thank you again yeah i gotta go get some thank you nikki
for the sponsor yes thank you so much yes if you want to
support me and my child please feel free to click the link
pinned in our chats and our panels will help us out a lot
yeah the more exclamation point nikki to get it yeah yeah
yeah you can't find the link just do exclamation point nikki
for to you know click and then click on the link as well
again thank you for the sponsor thank you tv i'm gonna go so
stay a little longer and then to to i guess like i'll read
them a bedtime story yeah calm down yeah and then you can
transfer both our viewers to one lucky person yeah we'll
send them somewhere yeah that'll be nice yeah yeah all right
bye bye tv adios oh yes oh
hey guys i had a great time seeing my child again um it has
been a while i know we're supposed to that we haven't been
done part two of the other game that we were doing together.
But we were both so busy.
We were both so busy.
But thank you again to the sponsor for sponsoring Chibi and
I.
I had a great time with her, as always.
She is very fun to talk to.
I mean, she is my child.
So of course, like we have the same sense of humor,
obviously, because she inherited those genes from me.
I'm a natural, of course.
but hey guys i hope y'all have fun hanging out with us i'm
gonna go head off now tomorrow is my rest day um huge shout
out to uh my staff uh my sponsor staff for handling this i
was very snappy earlier today about it because we were
trying to figure some stuff out so obviously when i feel
very pressured and everything i get super snappy um and like
during the message that's why like join behind the scenes so
um here's shout out to the staff that handles my sponsors
and does the briefing and everything for me um and for
tanking my snappiness during this um hey guys again thank
you to uh thank you to our the sponsor as well as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everyone bye guys bye i will not be streaming tomorrow just
so you guys know also also i forgot i'm on twitch now i keep
forgetting i'm on twitch i just forgot i was on twitch for
those who don't know me my name is jokey bert and i usually
stream on youtube but today i'm on twitch because it's for a
sponsor um so you guys want to check me out check out my
content please feel free to follow me on youtube as well and
follow me on twitter because that's when i tweet out
whenever i'm on twitch yeah check me out on twitch as well
if you want to i'm on twitch i mean we're on twitch right
now check me on twitter as well you want to follow more
twitch streams uh whenever i do stream on twitch um what
else what else um uh you want to support me via other means
uh please feel free to uh buy my merch i have a lot of merch
collaborations going on right now um i got the uh my doki
merch my uh my controller my pro controller my knives a lot
of stuff going on um yep that should be everything stuff
done as always everybody say i already said that sorry i'm
all over the place um heading off now bye guys bye i'll go
raid tv uh bye everyone bye i'm like i'm just letting you
guys know i'm like so socially drained right now my my uh
battery is like so dead i i'm like i'm i'm so my battery is
like so burnt out right now i'm charging at 10 every day uh
because i've been like filling it out with i've had so many
collabs lately so most like i'm gonna i but the thing is the
next couple of weeks there's a lot of like collabs going on
as well like a lot of like sponsored collabs as well as like
uh pre-planned stuff as well so we're gonna do our best um
we're gonna do our best anyway guys uh bye bye guys bye but
like i said is always a natural to so many buys but i'm like
but wait there's more uh but really thankful to have the
sponsor with uh chibi because you know it makes it so much
more we're like we roll around very naturally very natural
chemistry um so it was very easy with the back and forth
with her so i really always have fun doing stuff like this
with her uh but yeah that's really it that's my final word
on it vote for her for vtuber of the year uh um because you
know she's nominated for vtuber year so feel free to vote
for her as well all right anyway guys bye for video.
Bye-bye.